okay so did you know that the players in
squid game could have actually seen what
games they'd be playing before they even
played them between the matches the
characters were all placed into a room
filled with bunk beds and though this
seemed just like a rest area if you look
at the walls they're actually filled
with significant markings as the beds
get slowly stripped away it's revealed
that these paintings are actually all of
the games that the players would be
playing throughout the tournament first
is red light green light there's also
the honeycomb game tug of war the glass
hopping one the three at the table and
lastly the titular squid game the series
itself is filled with clues to the
eventual reveals and this is also the
case with the player who's behind the
entire thing it's absolutely
mind-blowing and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
but i just want to give a huge spoiler
alert for the series if you haven't
checked it out then this is your chance
to quit playing but if you want to
continue then i hope you thumbs up the
video and also subscribe to the channel
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into squid game
okay so at the end of squid game we
learned that it was ill-nam all along
the final episode reveals that he
invented the games as a form of
entertainment for him and his rich
buddies who had become bored with life
we learned that he had actually got
involved in the one that we see in the
show because he was dying and wanted a
final bit of fun in his life before it
was too late the ending was absolutely
incredible and the scene had jihan
saying goodbye to the character as he
lay on his deathbed this last meeting
actually reflected their first one in
which he too encountered the character
as he sat in a bed it was a pretty big
twist that pulled the rug out from under
your feet but eagle-eyed viewers might
have spotted early on that there were
several clues pointing towards his true
identity the first one is that he is
number one the very first player if we
look at the subtext of the series
g-hunter is the final number and
throughout he watches he very much works
his way to first place aka ilnam in the
final episode he's left as number one he
inherits a large portion of the
character's fortune and comes face to
face with him in one of the final scenes
one is symbolic on a number of levels
and because it's the first place it also
hints to us that illnam is number one
and that he's the one controlling
everything in episode five wang jun ho
sneaks through the compound and he
eventually finds a storage room with
files on all of the games that have
happened over the decades upon opening
the 2021 the first player there is
actually number two and illness profile
is completely missing there is no file
for number one because he doesn't need
or want to keep a record for himself the
other players in the game also somewhat
hint towards us that something is off
with illness and though it's not too
obvious when you really think about it
he wouldn't be someone that would be
selected for the process everyone else
in the squid game is roughly the same
age whereas he's extremely elderly he's
also dying of a brain tumor and thus
even if he did win the life-changing
money it wouldn't last that long though
he gives his reasons as to why he wants
it from what we know about the games and
the players that have been selected in
the past they're all roughly between 20
and 40 and he's a complete outlier in
all of this now the games themselves are
also major giveaways too throughout the
series we watched as he said they were
all things that he'd played as a child
and in retrospect it becomes blatantly
obvious that he selected them himself
because they're what he knows on repeat
viewings it's clear that each of them
are something that he not only played as
a kid but they're also things that he's
very very good at the first thing they
play is red light green light whilst the
other players are absolutely terrified
for their lives he gleefully struts
about whilst the terminator's back is
turned and even stops before it looks
back to face the crowd he knows all of
the lyrics to the song that the machine
sings and therefore knows to stop in
advance before ends and turns back
around if we look at the clip of the
targeted players you might also notice
something different about him the one
directly to his left and all of the
other ones to the side have a slight
green overlay that appears over the top
of them if we look at the players to his
right outside of the girl crouching down
beside him this is also the case too
everyone other than him in this girl's
track suit appears slightly green and i
believe that this machine sees him
without the glow because it's been
programmed not to shoot him if this
theory is right then he also has a
protective ring around him that stops
the machine from firing at people in his
vicinity in case it misses and that's
why the girl to his right is also safe
too immediately after this game the
players decide to cast a vote on whether
they should end the tournament or not he
is the one who makes the choice in the
end and casts the deciding boat to end
the game this subtly shows his power
over the entire thing and i actually
think that he carried this out for a
specific reason he wanted to give the
players a chance to walk away from all
knowing the stakes and if they came back
then that would ease his conscience
slightly as the choice was theirs now
cut to the honeycomb game and illness
ends up choosing the star though this
seems like a very complex shape there's
not actually any bends in it like the
circles or umbrellas though you might
think it's easier to have the triangle
the triangle's lines are longer whereas
the stars are shorter so there's less to
cut through before you hit an edge being
completely honest though yeah that the
triangle is a pretty easy shape too but
illness didn't exactly have one of the
difficult ones either next we jump to
episode 4 in which your fight breaks out
during the night throughout ilnam hides
away from the carnage up on one of the
bleachers and he ends up begging for the
fighting to stop even though up until
this point it seemed like the front man
was completely in control he immediately
sends the guards in because illness
requests it another clue is that his bed
is the only one that isn't flipped and
this is because the gods likely know who
he is
next they play a game of tug of war and
because of their players it seems like
ilnam's team are about to be sent to
their deaths however he is the one who
tells them how to win and because of his
guidance they easily beat the much
stronger team illnam had clearly played
the game hundreds of times before and
knew the best strategy to take any team
with him was destined to win and the
fact his strategy works definitely
proves this the final game in which he
takes part is the marbles one and this
also has a lot of clues in it throughout
it it seems like the character is struck
by dementia and he constantly walks
around looking for his house this game
not only pulls from his childhood but
the area does too and unless the squid
game organizers were psychic then they'd
have no way of knowing what his home
looked like throughout the episode
everything he says is brushed away is
the ramblings of someone with the
disease but knowing what we know it
becomes all the more obvious that he's
in control in the end he seems to find
his home and personally i believe that
this is a perfect recreation of it he's
giving the game away because throughout
the entire season he's letting us know
that all of the challenges and
environments are based on things from
his life he lets jihun win and the
character is then seemingly killed off
camera but we know that isn't the case
if we look closely at the gate that
jihan has just walked out of we can see
that he's no longer there and though the
rest of the court is filled with bodies
his is completely missing now knowing
what we know a question you may have is
why did ilnam end up leaving the game at
this point when he was still invested in
playing well the next game is the deadly
hopscotch one and this is by far the
most unpredictable of the lot if he
didn't end up getting put in last place
then there would be a danger that the
person behind him could push him to his
death like what we see in the episode
there's also the possibility that due to
his brain tumor he may have forgotten
along the way which glass to step on and
he simply couldn't risk it now that is
of course a theory but overall going
back and knowing what we know i actually
think the series becomes better on a
second watch now obviously i'd love to
hear if you spotted any other ones below
and if this is your first time here then
i hope you enjoyed your trip to the
heavy spoilers show we are running
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the zak standard dc
trilogy and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of squid game which will
be linked on screen right now we've also
done one for midnight mass and both of
those series are really really good so
yeah hopefully i see you over there
right after this if not then thank you
for staying until the end i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you on
the next one take care peace
you